ah
[Música]
la resistencia a la vacuna en eeuu está
centrada principalmente entre los
conservadores los evangélicos y los
americanos en áreas rurales sobre todo
el sur de eeuu haber usado la pandemia
como una arma electoral y las teorías
conspirativas han hecho que apenas esta
semana se logre la meta de vacunación
del 70% de adultos en eeuu esto en medio
del repunte de casos de la variable
delta que volvió a pasar la barrera de
los 80 mil casos diarios reportados en
este país al respecto el presidente
valiente está pidiendo a los políticos
republicanos que cambien su discurso y
usen su poder para salvar vidas y evitar
que los hospitales vuelvan a llenarse en
este sentido le pidió a los gobernadores
de texas y de la florida que se acojan
al mandato de porte de máscaras
independientemente del estado de
vacunación de sus habitantes pero éstos
aunque sus estados son focos de contagio
siguen haciendo caso omiso
[Música]
si bien en méxico no existe como tal un
movimiento anti vacunas si se ha
detectado la presencia de ciertos grupos
con falsas creencias que buscan
desinformar a la sociedad algunos
especialistas en salud pública advierten
que si bien no son significativos las
autoridades no deberían desestimar los
lo que si ha representado un serio
obstáculo es la reticencia que se ha
generado en varias comunidades con
población predominantemente indígena en
el sureño estado de chiapas donde desde
el surgimiento de la pandemia se ha
negado a creer en la existencia de la
misma y ahora rechazan la aplicación de
las vacunas con algunas ideas como que
pueden provocarles la muerte oa los
hombres dejarlos impotentes es cierto
que hace falta más información en
lenguas indígenas que es lo que se habla
en esta zona del país sobre todo de
origen maya pero además la
desinformación que cunde en redes
sociales ha provocado que chiapas sea
uno de los estados con más baja
cobertura en la campaña de vacunación
anti coma
[Música]
a pesar de las recientes manifestaciones
que reunieron miles de antigua cuna en
varias ciudades de italia el comisario
para la emergencia general francisco
filólogo anunció que por lo menos el 60%
de los italianos estos serían unos 32
millones y medio de los mayores de 12
años ya tendrían una pauta completa de
la vacunación se espera alcanzar la
inmunidad de rebaño es decir un 80 por
ciento para el mes de septiembre el
primer ministro mario draghi anunció el
uso del green pass o pasaporte verde
para el próximo 6 de agosto lo que
incrementado la cantidad de personas
reservando la vacuna en un 200% la
universidad estatal de milán hizo un
estudio a más de 18.000 personas que
encontró que por lo menos el 85 por
ciento de éstos estarían dispuestos a
vacunarse sólo entre un 5 a un 3 por
ciento estaría en negado rotundamente a
ponerse la vacuna es decir los anti
vacunas lo que pues obviamente con estos
números podría llevar a cabo que para el
mes de septiembre el gobierno italiano
alcance su objetivo
[Música]